i first started out uh
making the films
and
i never thought i could believe when i
hit 100 films
and now i'm
just on hitting 200
and i look back at
how many views i get
and i've made someone lazy yoga as i
call it because i teach just
one yoga pose
per film
and try to go through in depth
some chicon from tai chi
and then
some meditation
then
aikido
now the aikido
i've increased because that's where the
most hits are and that's because i'm
reaching an audience
who
chose
aikido
at some stage
when i go to uh
my face is suffering some injuries at
the moment but this is through uh not
being very well in the last month
but
we all have
occasionally illnesses
i'm very fortunate
i don't want to go on about myself too
much
but nearing
72 now
when i go to the chiropractor once a
year i like a checkup
she's always amazed at how flexible
and how in good condition my body is
now
going back
to in my 50s
was when i actually stopped training
i stopped physical training through
through to
arthritis in my knees hands
bad shoulder
and various other things that it was
just too painful to do vigorous training
and i am of the mind perhaps like
yourself
if i can't train 100
then why train at all
and i found teaching
replace training
when i say replaced
um really
the physical cardiovascular
i didn't get and that's what you don't
get through teaching
yes you get uh
other things
if i try to walk every day
i try to do yoga as many times as i can
sometimes i'll do it day after day after
day
for a period continuous period perhaps a
month two months
perhaps i'll only do it once a month one
day
it depends how i feel
and i've always been like that
but i'm very flexible still
for my age and
and i
i have a
pulse rate of a 53
so
whatever i've done
is obviously
paid off or paying off
none of us know how long we've got to
live
and that i cannot determine but while
i'm here i should try to keep in the
best condition possible
now
it sounds like me me me but really it's
you you i'm talking to
because what disheartens me
is that you're all wanting the answer to
aikido
but you should be all wanting
the answer to what i've just been
talking about the answer to
health
fitness
low heartbeat
you should be trying to keep in good
condition
yes
i need to lose weight i've been on a
dart
since i was 19.
i've always felt as if i've been
overweight and perhaps i have
when i went to one in 1994 i definitely
wasn't overweight
i was very thin very fit
and still not prepared for what cytosexy
dished out
in the dojo there
very demanding
so back to my message here
you may think but you don't have time to
fit anything else in
but if you want to be good and
understand aikido
you do need to do other things
you see aikido is a very young martial
art
it's not even 200 years old 950 years
old
we don't know all the things about it
yet we are
you me we we're creating the future like
you know
sadly the techniques have been diluted
and it's becoming more
like a exercise of dance
in many dojos
other dojos it's harder
nails you know really hard style
but
whatever you
see i could have as
hard or soft
it's you that's doing it it's you that
needs to
take this journey the same as i've taken
it
so i suggest if nothing else you try and
follow
either yoga class
or on youtube
try to try to get into your body and
find how difficult it
is to
to do some of these poses you'll find
your struggle
all the things that i've done have been
will say mishaps
i've fallen into them not really
intending to
but i'm so glad i did
meditation
when a person's in front of you
especially with the ken
you're about to start a kumitachi
your nerves
if you're a sensitive person your nerves
will be on edge
wondering when is the point that you
should start or when is the point they
will start
when you get it right all these things
racing through your mind but learning
meditation
you learn to gaze at them
like i'm gazing in the camera
and you softly without closing your eyes
like i am
with your eyes wide open you find
stillness
you find peace
you don't look for when they're going to
start when you're going to start
you will sense it
and you'll know
and this has to be practiced
or you can practice it through learning
basic meditation
but that's you need this
when your adrenaline's running high
because you've had so much enjoyment
doing the kumitaches or the kumijo or
just throwing
a group of people in a lineup
you need to know how to bring yourself
down
how to calm yourself so that you're
ready for any action
like i said
aikido is very young
so since he didn't
tell us about
all the things that we should do we just
took the
mechanical side
nobody seems to want to take the
flexibility side
the things you should be doing to look
after your body
you've got one body or one life
my advice to you is
even if you don't want to fit
these other things in
you need to try to pick something else
rather than just the technical parts of
like at home
they might give you 100
satisfaction now
but will your body last or will you have
to walk away
will you become a teacher perhaps you'll
have enough knowledge
but will you only have knowledge to
teach technical
or were you about to look at the people
on the map and look at their bodies and
think
that person is too tight too stiff
that person's friendly
and relaxed but a little too relaxed how
would you help them how would you say
drop your shoulders relax
you might be able to give them an
exercise if you knew yoga on how to over
the
next few weeks how to relax their
shoulders so it becomes part of them and
their training gets better
this is not to
beat you up or to tell you what you've
got to do
i'm just telling you what i've done
and looking at how many hits the
meditation
the chi kung
the lazy yoga is getting
is so low
that you don't realize what you're
missing
aikido will not give you on its own
we are creating the aikido of the future
of since he gave us the techniques
but them alone
it's like having all the fruit
but but we but placing them on a nice
plate a nice bowl
when somebody comes to see you
so the whole picture looks nice
it
should be important to you
so that you can keep training as long as
possible and when your time comes to
become just a teacher
then you'll have a lot of wisdom and a
lot of knowledge so you're exploring
please find time
to consider this
and perhaps you don't need a new year to
come around to make a resolution
because every new day
is a single new day that you'll never
get back
thank you for your time